[Musique]
h3 a atteint bientôt 26 quiz et jeux
d'eau se trouve sur un pee wee ce nom je
ne ferai pas à manger ça suffit j'ai dit
non officiellement les pommes de terre
sautées jump into the pool way sacré
piscine
j'en perds la tête ça va ou pas georges
actu la note celle là stop les tons je
ne tomberai pas je veux aller de l'autre
côté le côté de la liberté le côté des
spartiates
voilà à plus haut face aux pistons je
recherchais c'est mon fiston la justice
en flèche dans le coeur on avance le
yoyo des gens bons offices ton fils ton
si tu es là tout va bien
oui papa j'ai perdu mes jambes si je te
vois les tiennent tout va bien c'est
pourquoi pas je te montre tel un cheval
allez vas-y toi t'en avec ta chaussures
j'aime ça ok ça va mais c'est l'afflux
des roues quoi aux dires des haricots
rouges ont pas senti le code carnet on
est prêt pour un bon coup de fitness
aléas et devrait doper un fait le fiston
suis moi mieux mais des jeunes patriotes
fiston de sentis capables de m'aider
papa tu as pas de force des mollets oui
non mais attends le mur m'a séduit par
une superbe journée en or il n'y a rien
pour moi lors du décès je veux retrouver
mon mur sans lui et ça démarre la ligne
d'arrivée c'était plus aux pistons je
vais tenter le plus gros et willy du
monde
non pas que je vais tomber d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je t'avais dit
de te taire et de laisser je m'en vais
de manière ridicule c'est parti bah
voilà c'est bien comme ça je suis va
nous donner une bonne note d'acrosport
même si ça n'a rien à voir
voilà comme ça c'est parfait fiston ne
bouge plus papa je me suis pas levé les
pieds oui je sais bolton boost
c'est quoi le troll tonnes boost ah oui
surtout qu'avec la force
gravitationnelle fois cucquois mots
viennent gestion fiston
augusto bastos dans mon corps c'est
juste normal là j'ai cru que j'allais
mourir pistou crise - boire un petit peu
de bon sens et un brochage mon fiston
j'essaie de voilà de tram n'est sûr
monde au fiston bien là à les festons
voilà éjection non fils tout à piston g
a pu revoir mes tétons tu es jaloux je
suppose ok donc deux bras arraché de mon
corps qui se serrent la main comme s'il
était en train de se dire bien jouer on
l'a bien indiqué on s'est enfin libéré
de son temps ça c'est scandaleux on va
tricher on va pour le mec et son hélico
a malheureusement il n'a pas d'hélico
beau jeu ce businessman
oh oui on va se faire un business man
pardon j'aimerais affronter un business
man tu as plus de têtes n'essaie pas de
se recoiffer tu crois que je te vois pas
et a hâte de sortir mes fesses testons
jeu devra fiston attention j'ai
désormais la tête qui pendent oui space
voilà donc ça c'est le flou bieber de
rêver allez on est déjà à 2,4 à nong
paris bagdad
c'était le nom du niveau et puis j'aime
bien indien des bisous avec une boutique
natural bon voilà on pousse le niveau
allait bien avec le dictateur allemand
en haut mais qu'est ce que c'est john
fellas bienvenue parmi nous tu auras
tout ce qu'il faut ici ou pas du tout
welcome to variant city c'est parti
aussi l'esquivé incroyable je te ramène
chez papa allez je suis gentil je te
ramène à la maison hop tu dégages
et maintenant c'est la femme aille et
c'est oui non mais là lui il a quelques
kilos en trop il a carrément stoppé la
machine bon voilà ça arrive à eau et à
des revues mais je rentre pas dans le
canon c'est nul
et puis ça mon casque de vélo je n'ai
plus aucun style fiston tout ce qui nous
reste à faire dans ce moment-là éjection
je peux pas me joindre sur quoi c'est
sur la scène
tant pis pour toi fiston je suis le seul
qui fait des bisous au mur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
can you survive attendait
non mais là c'est juste impossible quoi
regarder mon torse
est-ce que je ressemble plus à un steak
charal désormais et bien sûr que oui ok
ok au le dernier il était là il était
comme ça tapis dans l'ombre et d'un coup
il a fait c'étaient les limitations
le car s'est fait rattraper par le bras
c'était magnifique on aurait dit une
magnifique scène d'amour dans un film
alors qu'en fait on est sur un pee wee
c'est que c'est juste un coeur qui a
rencontré un bras tous deux ont arraché
d'un corps fraîchement décapiter l eco
up to run mais des chocs fondez-vous
comme ça est ce qu'ils se rendent compte
que l'amusement est impossible hier des
lola il reste plus que sa belle chemise
un bon c'est un certain style comme j'ai
mal fou de vous voilà je suis mort
et ma tête de finir dans les faits ce
qui on le loue ou deux où là je fait
l'autruche
aux saluts le toit d'immeubles best
lobel ever premièrement la modestie s'il
vous plaît c'est juste ça le niveau très
bien flatteur à l'étude ouais on s'est
tu es magnifique on notera la petite
hache qui a fini dans son crâne tips
grab the glass et mme bragg alors déjà
c'est pas comme ça qu'on attend quelque
chose la seule chose que tu ai attrapé
s'était pied non non c'est pas grave
j'aime bien cette position je suis
l'homme le plus stylé du monde
je vais à une vitesse incroyable ce
sabre affilé dans les testicules jetons
une mauvaise expérience avec les sabres
d'un pee wees c'est bike folle je sens
un niveau bien nul vous avez vu ce mot
niveau et climatique
ça c'était le dangereux dictateur
allemand avec un cheveu sur la langue et
hop le devoir m'appelle je suis super
man en réalité même si je m'envole a dû
à leur faim can dance
qu'est ce que c'est que cette vision
était incessant qu'est ce que c'est que
ça on notera quand même que cet homme à
gauche marchaient sur des braises
nous savons que c'est pas doivent pas
pas car encore une fois ça peut compter
de l'été chaussures est là pour me
sauver le wedding bells est ce que c'est
pas le bon moment pour faire une douche
partie bien sûr que s'ils n'y était pas
a renchéri on a branché bâton pourquoi
parce que si tu te branche
[Musique]
mais regardez pas comme ça taxis